i'm encouraging everyone listening uh
once upon a time in hollywood obviously
the movie was and is uh a true delight
now have you read the thing that we
added to the uh well here's what i love
the the screenplay for a bounty law
episode yes here's what i love because
you're this is you this is the essence
of i call you qt behind your back
but but the essence of quentin tarantino
is so you write this very good novel
novelization of
and it's and again this is not this is
not a replication of what happens in the
movie it's sort of a deeper dive in some
ways and and and uh but then tell the
story
it's the same story but i tell them a
vaguely different way a very different
way yeah and then um then you get to the
end and you have written i believe
a script
for a tv episode of bounty law
and
and you have a very realistic
front page of the script with a coffee
coffee ring with a coffee ring on it and
it says it's written by robert fuzz
yes don't know who the [ __ ] that is
and it says revised final draft uh july
6
1959
and then it's a very good
bounty law episode you gotta you get a
sense of the show yeah episode of bonnie
law and then you have all of this like
the bounty law lunch box and comic books
the comments the tv guides yes which are
and then you have the mad magazine yes
parody of bounty law
which is fantastic okay it's spot-on
okay this is the perfect last story for
uh uh for this episode that you will
appreciate okay go back again to the
cover of the the mad magazine there oh
yeah yeah yeah okay got it okay so the
idea was okay
he's gonna uh when it comes to rick's uh
apartment yep an apartment his house
he's gonna have like you know uh some of
his posters will be upgraded
and like the tv guides that he's on
he'll have those framed but also
was the idea that uh mad would have done
a uh a spoof of of bounty law and so he
would have had the cover of that and so
we went to um the mad magazine people
and we said
look what we want to do
is we want to have the uh a real mad
magazine cover that you guys draw and we
want to draw as if we want to draw as if
jack davis was doing the drawing right
right and and i had the whole idea in my
mind that it would be alfred newman on
the wanted poster with his finger up his
nose
and uh and rick kind of doing a double
take when he sees him yep so i described
to them exactly what i wanted for the
poster and they go okay and so they have
their jack davis guy
and he went it and and and he drew it
and then when it was done it looked so
terrific perfect and then we came back
to us and then um
we said hey look guys i don't know if
you want to do this or not but if you
want to do it uh we can show you all the
footage we shot for bounty law and if
you wanted to do it a spoof from the
magazine of boundary law lousy law i'm
the one that came up with the lousy law
you know we would be into that well they
thought that was kind of a good idea too
so they came down into the editing room
and we showed them all the bounty law
footage we had and then they wrote their
little spoof and then they came out with
it um so they used that that cover as
their real cover yep and then they had
the the spoof in the magazine it turned
out
that that was the last original episode
uh
last original issue of mad magazine ever
published oh you're kidding me they
still publish mad magazine but it's all
it's reprinted yes i've actually seen
that because i've run across some and i
wanted my son to know because mad
magazine was such a big deal to me and i
used to
actually
always go to the movie spoofs yeah yeah
yeah absolutely and i would read those
and often
really good crit movie criticism yeah
really good movie criticism and also
often i read those without seeing them
yeah that happened a bunch of times
before i'm like i don't need to see this
movie okay but you're you're not getting
the most important part of this story
conan sorry
i
designed and formatted the cover of the
last original mad magazine issue i want
to put a little twist on your summation
you killed mad magazine
what about that